[Music]
or as serious as farcry story takes
itself the games open world is filled
with a light-hearted nonsense and plenty
of goofs so of course that means there's
a lot of fun Easter eggs and references
to be found from both other Ubisoft
games and even some real world events
here's all the ones we found so far
there's a small homage to far cry 3's
famous villain vos who you can see in
the form of a bobblehead any standard
vehicle you purchase comes with a small
customization selection and if you pick
up the Hawaiian bobblehead you will be
treated to Voss rocking a hula skirt and
ukulele but that's not all using Ubisoft
Club you can get yourself a bobblehead
of Far Cry 4s villain pagan min and one
of those pesky little Rabbids southwest
of Ray Ray's pumpkin farm in the Holland
Valley is a small cave known as
frobisher's cave inside you'll find some
primitive cave paintings no doubt a
small reference to Far Cry primal
Far Cry 3 Blood Dragon is one of the
best examples of a cheesy idea turned
into a real thing so it's great to see
it getting more loved with an entire
side mission devoted to it over at the
Grimalkin rad on mine in the henbane
River is a movie shoot for Blood Dragon
3 run by the narcissistic director guy
marvel's classic tale a small town
nobody jew arrives just in time to save
world renowned ohter guy marvel yours
truly my movie my masterpiece is four
[ __ ] years in the making and I will
not have it derailed but these [ __ ]
plebs with no cinematic vision it's
weird enough seeing Far Cry 3 Blood
Dragon posters in the Far Cry game but
they also seem to be implying that guy
Marvel used to make Far Cry games oh my
head hurts
blood dragon 3 will be a masterpiece
seriously it has to be I can't go back
to working on [ __ ] like Far Cry I'd
rather put my balls in a vise and listen
everyone with their [ __ ] opinions
about world building and player
motivation and believability oh I'll
kill myself I swear to [ __ ] god the
best part of the whole thing though is
that you get to listen to some of blood
dragons killer soundtrack
completing that Blood Dragon mission
unlocks you the Omega outfit which
stresses you up like a cyborg soldier
from blood dragon there is other outfits
as well though there's a Rainbow six
siege outfit which lets you look like
operator castle and a Far Cry primal
outfit both of which you can get through
Ubisoft Club credit goes to Taz Adar HD
over on reddit for finding this
reference to it the Stephen King novel
which was turned into a bad TV
mini-series and then turned into a just
okay movie oh yeah
hey if you want to find it for yourself
head over to the hope county jail bus
just west of Falls End in the Holland
Valley and then follow the river a short
distance south
[Applause]
[Music]
while far Prime's narrative seems to be
trying to avoid correlations to
modern-day events
it looks like Ubisoft just couldn't help
themselves with the emission Patriot
Act's I've been sent here on a special
mission from the big man himself
jesus-tap-dancing-christ just saying
that gets me semi-erect pardon my french
I need to recover a tape that if
released could make him look bad to the
public
special agent Willis Huntley who is a
returning character from both Far Cry 3
& 4 tasks you with removing a tape
filled with sensitive information as the
mission progresses you learn the tape is
held by undercover Russians and it has
something to do with liquid follow that
chopper to Boyd's house let the target
get in and they'll lead you down the
yellow brick road remember as ironic as
this may sound this is not a Wetworks
mission if you haven't already figured
it out this is not so subtly referring
to the infamous donald trump p tape the
american way used to mean a deal was a
deal but we live in a new America now I
know you're wishing for a handout but
that's just how it is
this one is a bit hard to confirm as
fully true but it's a funny story so
it's worth sharing a while back PC
gamers James Davenport wrote an open
letter to Ubisoft asking them to put his
dad a born Montanan into the game
James slider wasn't all that serious but
lo and behold there is a location in the
Holland valley called Davenport farm if
you search around there is not too much
alluding to James dad until you find a
note which reads it is a well-known fact
that bovines are the most erotic animals
on God's green earth sometimes I sneak
out here so I can watch Bulls have sex
with the cows please don't tell my
father so either this is a massive
coincidence or Ubisoft has completely
troll the James while not exactly hidden
there is a fun little reference alluding
to the infamous tower climbing open
world structure of Ubisoft's open-world
games which has actually been removed
from Far Cry 5 it occurs during the
games tutorial when you are made to
climb a radio tower
capitalizing on farcry forests famous
secret ending far cry 5 has won as well
and the opening of the game you follow
the sheriff and marshal into the church
to try and arrest a joseph's heed when
prompted with the button to handcuff him
simply do nothing and wait a few minutes
and you'll get the game secret ending
we're live in row far cry 5 arcade is a
new mode where you can participate in
co-op challenges and traditional PvP
multiplayer the catch is that all of the
maps are customized using the game's
robust map editor which gives you access
to not only all of the assets from Far
Cry 5 but from other Ubisoft games as
well
stuff like far cry 4 is Himalayan
statues watchdogs urban buildings
assassin's creed 4 black flags pirate
treasure primals tribal huts and unities
french architecture it's really cool to
see all of these assets from other
Ubisoft games in this map editor and I'm
really looking forward to seeing what
kind of crazy creations people will come
up with so that's everything we found so
far in Far Cry 5 if you've got any
Easter eggs or fun references we've
missed let us know in the comments below
[Music]